ZDF heute live herzliches Willkommen
euch allen toll dass ihr mit dabei seid
wir wollen heute mal wieder in die
Ukraine schauen denn in den letzten
Tagen lag der Fokus der Weltpolitik der
krisendiplomatie doch gefühlt
ausschließlich auf Israel auf den
Terrorangriff der Hamas auf Israel und
dennoch ging parallel dazu der russische
Angriffskrieg auf die Ukraine
unvermindert weiter und es gibt in
dieser Woche auch einzelne Meldungen und
Neuigkeiten auf die wir heute schauen
wollen und über die wir heute sprechen
wollen vor allem die Ostukraine ist
weiterhin ein schwer umkämpftes Gebiet
im Fokus liegt da besonders die
Kleinstadt avdevga die einer größeren
Angriffswelle ausgesetzt ist und wir
sehen hier aktuelle Bilder entsprechend
vor Ort ist die Zerstörung dann kamen in
dieser Woche neuelieferte Raketen aus
den USA zum Einsatz gegen Russland und
laut Ukraine konnten diese sogenannten
attackems Raketen auch schon erste
Erfolge erzielen 2017 wurden sie noch in
Südkorea von den USA getestet das sind
ja Archivbilder von diesen Tests die wir
sehen und jetzt eben mittlerweile sind
sie eben im Einsatz in der Ukraine wir
haben deshalb heute für euch ein Update
vorbereitet und fragen was passiert in
der Ukraine wollen dazu gleich reden mit
unserer ZDF Korrespondentin Anne Brühl
die in Kiev sitzt und wir haben heute
auch den Militärexperten Nico lange zu
Gast und freuen uns auf all eure Fragen
die ihr uns wieder schicken könnt eure
Meinungen und Kommentare wie immer geht
das über die Kommentarspalten zu jeder
Zeit oder ihr schickt uns eine E-Mail an
zdfheute-live@zdf.de und damit begrüße
ich auch unseren ersten Gesprächspartner
heute im ZDF Hauptstadtstudio ist er uns
zugeschaltet der Militärexperte Nico
lange einen schönen guten Abend nach
Berlin g Abend Herr Lange aktuelle
Meldung eben die Ukraine hat Anfang der
Woche neuelieferte attackems Raketen
wohl eingesetzt die Bilder haben wir
gerade auch schon gesehen erklären Sie
uns mal ganz kurz wie wichtig sind diese
Waffen für die
Ukraine die Ukraine hat attackems
eingesetzt und hat das überraschend
getan was auch richtig war damit
Russland sich nicht drauf einstellen
kann gerade diese ersten Angriffe waren
extrem wichtig und attackams sind Army
tactile Army tactical missile System
sind Raketen die Reichweiten haben in
dieser Variante die geliefert worden ist
von 165 km und bisher hat die Ukraine
mit heimas eine Reichweite von etwa 90
km das sind also 75 km mehr natürlich
kann man die nicht direkt an die Front
stellen sondern die muss man in
Sicherheit haben die abschussgeräte die
Launcher für diese attackemess aber wenn
man die dann benutzt kann man damit
genau diesen Küstenstreifen in der
Südukraine bearbeiten und erreicht damit
Ziele die bisher die Russen ganz bewusst
aus der Reichweite von heimas
rausgehalten haben das ist der
entscheidende Unterschied und und die
Ukraine hat jetzt den gesamten
Küstenstreifen zwischen der Frontlinie
und dem asofschen Meer in den
Reichweiten von ihren Präzisionswaffen
mhm als es zum Einsatz kam Anfang der
Woche haben die Agenturen dann auch als
bald vermeldet dass die Ukraine da schon
Erfolge erzielen konnte was haben Sie da
genau gehört ja das ist ja der Umstand
warum überhaupt bekannt geworden ist
dass diese Waffen da sind die Lieferung
selbst hat man natürlich geheim gehalten
damit Russland sich nicht drauf
einstellen kann
und die Waffen sind zum ersten Mal
eingesetzt worden gegen einen
Hubschrauber Landeplatz ein airfield in
der Nähe von berdjansk direkt an der
Küste dort hat sich Russland sicher
gefühlt und hat da z.B auch die
Alligator Kampfhubschrauber das sind
genau die Hubschrauber die auch den
kampfbanzern Schützenpanzern so viele
Probleme gemacht haben bei der
Gegenoffensive die hat Russland da
stationiert und die attackams die dort
eingeschlagen sind bei berdjansk die
haben ganz offenbar wenn man den Bildern
Glauben schenken darf verherende Wirkung
eingerichtet die Variante von attackams
die die Amerikaner an die Ukraine
geliefert haben bisher ist eine mit
einem Cluster Warhead also mit einem
Sprengkopf der in viele kleine Stücke
zerspringt und das natürlich auf einem
Flugfeld gegen Flugzeuge Hubschrauber
eine besonders wirkungsvolle Waffe und
diese Wirkung ist eben auch eingetreten
viele russische Beobachter auch
stationierte dort Soldaten haben von
verherenden Wirkung gesprochen wir reden
gleich noch weiter Herr Lange vielen
Dank für diesen Moment auch dann zu
möglichen offensiven offensiven die es
gab und geben wird und auch zu
Strategien und gerade dieses Themenfeld
ist ein Thema was unsere Userinnen und
User sehr stark interessiert da trudeln
schon die ersten Fragen ein die ich
gleich gerne an SIE weitergebe wir
wollen vorher noch auf die Situation der
Ukrainer der Menschen der
Zivilbevölkerung blicken denn der Krieg
ging unvermindert weiter und parallel
dazu gibt es nun noch einen neuen
krisenhert nämlich nach dem
Terrorangriff der Hamas auf Israel eben
diesen und da die Frage an Anne brü
unsere Korrespondentin in Kiev guten
Abend anne war das denn überhaupt ein
Thema bei den Menschen in der Ukraine
trotz des Krieges vor der Haustür wurde
darauf auch
geblickt ja das ist ein Thema hier ein
sehr großes und die Anteilnahme ist groß
und das Entsetzen auch dieser brutale
Überfall der Hamas viele Opfer unter der
Zivilbevölkerung das fühlt sich hier für
viele Ukrainer wirklich fast vertraut an
viele fühlen sich an den 20 Februar
erinnert den Beginn dieses Krieges hier
im ganzen Land und solche Äußerungen aus
Russland man möge doch bitte die
Zivilisten schonen Infrastruktur schonen
in diesem neuen Konflikt in dieser
Region das Empfinden hier viele sehr als
sehr zynisch weil genau das ja ist was
Russland hier macht Zivilisten angreifen
zivile Infrastruktur angreifen trotzdem
und auch das erleben wir immer weil wir
ja in den letzten Tagen auch viel
unterwegs waren beim drehen äh diese
Sorge vergessen zu werden die gibt's auf
der einen Seite auf der anderen Seite
sagen uns die Menschen dann bei diesen
tres wie gut dass ihr da seid wie gut
dass das deutsche Fernsehen auch noch
über diesen Krieg hier unseren Konflikt
hier berichtet und die Ukrainer merken
schon dass die Unterstützung weiter da
ist auch die militärische Unterstützung
ähm Deutschland z.B hat ja jetzt auch
noch mal dieses Winterpaket ähm ins
Leben gerufen mit äh vor allen Dingen
luen Waffen für die Luftverteidigung mm
du hast das gerade schon gesagt du bist
aktuell in Kiev warst aber die letzten
Tage im Land unterwegs hast dir den
Alltag angesehen der Ukrainerinnen und
Ukrainer unter anderem warst du jetzt in
einem Blutspendezentrum in kiefev und
dieser Eindrücke die du da eingefangen
hast die schauen wir uns mal kurz an die
Schlange ist lang an diesem Morgen im
Blutspendezentrum von kiefev die meisten
sind hier weil sie wissen dass ihr Blut
gebraucht wird auch für die Soldaten an
der
Front
jetzt verlieren wir so viele Menschen
viele verlieren so viel Blut man muss
diese Verluste
ausgleichen ich will der Gesellschaft
meinem Volk helfen wenn ich Blut spenden
kann ist das das wenigste was ich machen
kann Blutspenden für die die ihr Land
verteidigen gegen den russischen
Angriffskrieg für die die bei Raketen
und drohen Angriffen verletzt werden
seit Beginn des Kriegs hat die Zahl der
Blutspenden in der
Ukraine
zugenommen angefangen hat es am 24
Februar wir sehen seitdem dass wir jetzt
mehr Blutspender
haben sie wissen dass ihr Blut für einen
guten Zweck verwendet wird wir haben
jetzt einen großen
Bedarf das ist ein Symbol der Liebe und
der
Fürsorge vor dem Krieg hat das Zentrum
vor allem die Krankenhäuser beliefert
für Operationen nach Unfällen jetzt geht
vieles von hier gleich an die
Front
wir können alle Bedürfnisse die es gibt
abdecken sowohl für die zivile
Bevölkerung als auch für unsere
Streitkräfte Hilfe für Soldaten für die
Opfer in einem Krieg dessen Ende nicht
absehbar
ist der aktuelle Eindrück aus einem
Blutspendezentrum in Kier fren das von
Anne brül Anne kann man das sagen dass
das schon so zur neuen Normalität
geworden ist dass man die Soldaten
unterstützt dass man zum Blutspenden
geht und diese Schreckensmeldungen
eigentlich allgemein über Verluste jeden
Tag so hinnimmt bei den
Menschen ja das muss man leider sagen
das gehört hier irgendwie zum Alltag
also
ähm die Situation der Zivilisten ist ja
nun so dieser Krieg findet nicht an der
frontstatt Oder nicht nur an der
frontstatt sondern der Alltag der
Menschen die hier geblieben sind in
diesem Land der wird überall von
täglichen Angriffen der Russen auf Ziele
im ganzen Land bestimmt immer wieder
ertönt der
Luftalarm ich kenne viele die sagen ich
wünsche mir dass ich endlich mal wieder
eine Nacht durchschlafen kann und so
sieht eben der Alltag aus und das ist
sehr betrückend mhm dann
auch eine Sache die du recherchiert hast
wo du unterwegs warst du warst vor
kurzem mit einer staatlichen
rettungseinheit der Ukraine unterwegs
die Minen beseitigen jetzt nach diesen
ganzen Kriegsmonaten sind ungefähr so
offiz Schätzungen 30% der Ukraine durch
die Russen vermient das wird die
nächsten Jahre wahrscheinlich noch
dauern das ganze wieder zu entmienen
mittlerweile gibt's auch einige Regionen
von den man hört die komplett abgehängt
sind ähm was hast du da wahrgenommen wie
beeinflusst das den Alltag der
Menschen ja das beeinflusst ihn sehr
weil in viele dieser Orte können die
Menschen überhaupt nicht zurückkehren
obwohl sie das teilweise Orte sind wir
waren in der Region hakif und unterwegs
und das sind Orte die da in dieser
Gegenoffensive im vergangenen Herbst
also vor mehr als einem Jahr befreit
wurden aber diese rückkehren diese Orte
ist eben zu gefährlich weil die Russen
bevor sie abgezogen sind noch mal Minen
abgeworfen haben in ganz normale Gärten
in die Höfe der Menschen und diese
minenräumaktionen die laufen wir waren
da in einem kleinen Ort mit ein paar 100
Häuser und
die Männer vom staatlichen
Rettungsdienst die haben uns gesagt es
wird Jahre dauern Jahre allein nur um
diesen einen Ort zu entmienen und
natürlich haben die Anwohner auch Angst
zurückzukommen eine Frau die wir dort
getroffen haben deren Grundstück gerade
entmient wurde die sagte mein Nachbar
der hat sein Bein verloren als er auf
eine mene getreten ist das ist einfach
warahnsinnig gefährlich die Ukrainer
sagen von sich selbst sie sein im Moment
das größte Minenfeld der Welt Minen ist
das eine Problem die Jahreszeit ein
anderes Problem der nächste Winter kommt
du hast den letzten Winter als
Reporterin in der UK ihne miterlebt das
war damals schon ziemlich hart für die
Menschen jetzt eben gibt es Orte die
vermient wurden andere Orte sind äh ohne
Strom ohne Wasser wird dieser neue
Winter noch härter werden der jetzt
kommt als der
vorherige ja das befürchten hier einige
denn der letzte Winter war relativ mild
muss man sagen ähm das waren trotzdem
Temperaturen die ich erlebt habe von
ungefähr -10° und natürlich ist es auch
da nicht angenehm wenn der Strom
ausfällt und das war im letzten Winter
eben dauernd der Fall weil es immer
wieder diese Angriffe auf die
Infrastruktur gab wenn wir unterwegs
waren im Osten in der Region hakif z.B
damals auch im morgeneng grauen
weggefahren sind abends wieder
zurückkamen da sind wir manchmal an
Dörfern vorbeigekommen die komplett im
Dunkeln lagen da konnte man eigentlich
kaum sehen dass das überhaupt Dörfer
sind ja die Menschen dort die haben
teilweise die öffen in den Häusern die
können dann irgendwie Weizen die haben
einen Brunnen aber die Situation ist
natürlich schrecklich und in den
größeren Ortschaften gab es dann diese
Punkte der Unbesiegbarkeit so hat man
die genannt manchmal waren das
Räumlichkeiten manchmal aber einfach
auch nur Zelte da liefen dann
Generatoren da konnten die Menschen
hinkommen um wenigstens mal ihr Handy
aufzuladen ein heißen Tee zu bekommen
manchmal gab es auch essen so war die
Situation in den Dörfern in der Stadt in
hakil haben wir z.B auch mal einen
massiven Angriff mit erlebt da fiel dann
alles aus Strom Wasserheizung in der
zweitgrößten Stadt der Ukraine am
nächsten Morgen ging der Strom wieder
das hat mich damals sehr beeindruckt wie
schnell die Ukrainer auch immer in der
Lage waren
diese Schäden an der Infrastruktur dann
doch relativ schnell zu reparieren mhm
das nun Eindrücke aus der Ukraine der
Winter kommt und dann im nächsten Jahr
wird in Russland gewählt wir haben eine
Frage von Björn von Youtube der wissen
möchte Anne wie wahrscheinlich ist es
dass Russland nach den Wahlen im
kommenden Jahr jetzt ist die Frage
gerade verrutscht
pardon die Frage ist gerade verrutscht
aber er hatte gefragt wie wahrscheinlich
ist es dass nach den Wahlen im kommenden
Jahr eine neue Militäroffensive
ausgerufen wird in Russland was glaubst
Du also für Russland kann ich hier
schwer sprechen also ich glaube die
Menschen in der Ukraine die
konzentrieren sich jetzt auf das was was
hier gerade ist und ich meine die
russischen offensiven laufen ja jetzt
gerade auch im Osten diese kopiansk
liiman Front aufdevka habt ihr eben
gerade erwähnt also die die Russen
versuchen natürlich
dort auch weiter Druck zu machen weil
sie eben natürlich auch dieser
ukrainischen gegen Gegenoffensive im
Süden etwas entgegensetzen wollen und
natürlich ist das auch erfolgreich und
die Menschen die gucken da schon mit
Sorge drauf kopian z.B eine Stadt die
auch mal befreit wurde im letzten Jahr
da Leben kaum jetzt noch Menschen weil
die Russen wieder so nah an diese Stadt
herangerückt sind ich glaube da stehen
insgesamt mehr als 100.000 russische
Soldaten im Osten und das ist etwas was
die Menschen hier in der Ukraine was
denen Sorgen macht viele Sorgen dann die
kalte Jahreszeit Anne zum Abschluss
unseres Gesprächs vielleicht noch was
positives bei all diesen
Schreckensmeldungen die man so liest und
hört die dir auch begegnen die Sorgen im
Alltag gibt's auch irgendwie was
positives was dir die Menschen mal
erzählt haben gibt's noch Mut gibt's
noch Hoffnung in der
Ukraine ja die Hoffnung gibt's noch und
auch mich verwundert das manchmal nach
anderthalb Jahren Krieg die Worte die
ich jetzt auf Ukrainisch verstehe das
sind zwei nämlich mir Frieden und
peremocha Sieg und die Ukrainer die
benutzen diese Worte immer in einem Satz
das ist
deren Hoffnung und was ich trotz trotz
allem auch erlebe ist es gibt diese
Momente der Leichtigkeit und ich glaube
das ist auch total wichtig ich habe das
ja eben schon gesagt diese ständigen
Angriffe diese Nächte mit Luftalarm das
macht mürbe und die Menschen brauchen
auch diese Momente wo sie auftanken
können in Odessa z.B da waren wir im
August in in der Strandbar haben da
gedreht da gibt's dann am Wochenende
Party von 8 bis 10 weil um 10R alle nach
Hause müssen damit sie rechtzeitig vor
der Ausgangssperre wieder da sind ich
habe mich da mit einer jungen Studentin
unterhalten die hat gesagt ich habe
Geburtstag ich feiere zum ersten Mal
seit anderthalb Jahren ich mache Party
und ich möchte mir möchte niemanden der
mir deswegen Vorwürfe macht weil die
Studenten in Moskau die Feiern an diesem
Wochenende doch auch und natürlich
schwingt aber bei diesen Partys auch
immer so dieses Gefühl mit
das Leben genießen das Leben feiern weil
es so schnell zu Ende gehen kann nämlich
die vielen Toten die Verletzten das ist
ja die andere Realität die hier in der
Ukraine jeder in seiner Familie oder im
Freundeskreis auch ständig erlebt ja du
wirst die Lage weiterhin für uns im
Blick behalten anne brüh war das live
aus Kiev an ich danke dir für die Zeit
einen guten
Abend tschüss wir fragen heute was
passiert in der Ukraine und wollen
weiter ren mit unserem zweiten
Gesprächspartner der Militärexperte Nico
lange der uns zugeschaltet ist in Berlin
Herr Lange der Winter wird für die
Zivilbevölkerung nicht einfach das haben
wir gerade gehört von unserer Kollegin
wie schaut das denn bei den Soldaten
beider Seiten aus was haben sie gehört
wie ist das Stimmungsbild in den Truppen
aktuell ja wenn man mit den mit den
kommanduren den Soldaten spricht ist das
durchaus
unterschiedlich weil auch das Klima in
der Ukraine ja unterschiedlich ist also
im Süden und an der Südfront sind jetzt
vielleicht außer Regen keine total
großen Auswirkungen der Herbst oder
winterjahreszeit zu erwarten die
Kampfhandlungen werden dort weitergehen
das erwarte ich das ist eben nicht
Sibirien dort aber da wo das Klima
kontinentaler ist vor allen Dingen in
der Ostukraine da macht es einen großen
Unterschied ob man z.B mit der Truppe in
einer Stadt überwintern kann wo man die
Infrastrukturen nutzen kann wo man sich
besser aufwärmen kann wo man auch besser
Dinge lagern kann oder man muss das eben
auf dem offenen Feld tun
in den Schützengräben in den Stellungen
äh die häufig feucht werden wo schnell
da die Soldaten krank werden wo die
Kampfkraft gemindert wird und darum
scheint es aus meiner Sicht gerade auch
bei afdka zu gehen dass die Russen
versuchen mit großer Anstrengung diese
Stadt die ja schon seit 2014 direkt an
der Front liegt diese Stadt irgendwie
einzukreisen zu erobern um dann eine
bessere Ausgangsstellung zu haben für
den Winter um eine Plattform zu
entwickeln für die nächsten offensiven
denn daran besteht ja kein Zweifel
russland will sobald es kann oder sobald
die Ukraine Schwäche zeigt weiter ins
Land vorstoßen und weiter erobern
deswegen ist die Ukraine ja gezwungen
die gegenofensive weiterzuführen und die
Verteidigung weiterzuführen also wenn
man einfach sagen könnte wir hören jetzt
auf zu kämpfen und dann ist an dieser
Linie Schluss dann wäre das ja schon
problematisch genug das scheint sich bei
uns einige zu wünschen aber die Ukrainer
wissen wenn sie nicht weiterkämpfen wenn
sie nicht die Gegenoffensive
weitergestalten dann wird Russland alles
tun um weiter anzugreifen und weiter ins
Land vorzudringen mm Stichwort
offensiven sie haben es gerade schon
angesprochen auf dika stand im
Mittelpunkt der schlagzeahlen in dieser
Woche das britische
Verteidigungsministerium berichtet von
einer scheinbar koordinierten
Großoffensive Russlands in der
Ostukraine und auch einer unserer
Zuschauer Chris fragt allgemein mit
Blick auf den Winter wird es eine
Winteroffensive geben in den nächsten
Monaten was ist da ihre Einschätzung zu
ja wir wirutzen immer so ein bisschen
Begriffe die wir aus historischen
kriegen kennen bin da immer etwas
vorsichtig und und bei Winteroffensive
da hat man gleich irgendwie historische
Bilder im Kopf die überhaupt nicht
passen auf das was da in der Ukraine
passiert aber russland versucht immer
wieder zu gucken ob sich schwache Punkte
bei der Ukraine finden ob die Ukraine
Ressourcen im Süden einsetzt und dann
vielleicht andere Frontabschnitte etwas
geschwächt hat das sind keine
Großangriffe also man stellt sich da
immer große Formationen vor die da
angreifen das sind ja mehr so
abtastangriffe was russland versucht
aber es ist natürlich vor allen Dingen
Beschuss mit Artillerie und sind
Luftangriffe und das ist das
Hauptproblem dass an der Frontlinie im
Donbass aber auch im Süden
die Ukraine keine Luftüberlegenheit hat
und auch zu wenig Luftverteidigung
Russland kann relativ ungestört mit
Flugzeugen dort Luftangriffe fliegen
gleitbomben abwerfen und dort nicht nur
die zivilen Städte bombardieren sondern
auch den ukrainischen Truppen das Leben
schwer machen bei afdevka war es
allerdings so dass Russland versucht hat
mit gepanzerten Formationen also mit
Schützenpanzern und Kampfpanzern auch in
größeren Mengen von zwei Seiten dort
vorzudringen um die Stadt zu umfassen
und das ist schon ganz erstaunlich da
muss es einen sehr starken politischen
Befehl gegeben haben weil diese
Einheiten fast sinnlos in ukrainisches
Artilleriefeuer hineinelaufen sind und
sehr sehr viele russische Schützenpanzer
Kampfpanzer zerstört worden sind aber
die Angriffe gingen trotzdem immer
weiter als wenn dort Kommandeure sagen
koste ist was es wolle und wenn wir eben
so lange Truppen schicken müssen bis den
Ukrainern die Munition ausgeht wir
wollen hier irgend eine Art von
Durchbruch erreichen bisher ist das aber
nicht gelungen aber bei dieser
rücksichtslosen Art wie Russland mit den
eigenen Soldaten umgeht muss man davon
ausgehen dass die das weiter versuchen
werden mhm ähm für Unmut von der
russischen Seite sorgten die attackems
Raketen Wladimir Putin hatte sich
natürlich da direkt zu geäußert hat das
als Fehler betitelt den USA gegenüber
dass dass ich da eingemischt wurde hielt
im russischen Staatsfernsehen eine
Ansprache ist da jetzt ähm als Reaktion
vielleicht noch ein größerer Schlag zu
erwarten und auch dann gab es ja dann
diese Meldung dass sich gestern das
russische Parlament
m zurückziehen möchte aus dem Vertrag
Nukleartests durchzuführen auch das
interessiert unsere User wie schätzen
sie da die atomare Gefahr ein wenn es
immer schlechter läuft vielleicht
perspektivisch für Putin also wir kennen
das Spiel ja jetzt langsam und sollten
doch gelernt haben also Putin fand auch
schon die Lieferung der ersten
Panzerabwehrwaffe an die Ukraine einen
Fehler und er hat immer wieder gesagt
wenn das passiert dann ist aber eine
rote Linie überschritten passiert es gar
nichts also jetzt zu denken dass war ein
neues Waffensystem geliefert wurde macht
Putin irgendwas Neues oder
außergewöhnliches oder holt seine
geheime Reservearmee raus und jetzt geht
es aber richtig los das ist ja alles
nicht den Tatsachen entsprechend
russland hat überhaupt gar keine
weiteren Möglichkeiten zur Eskalation
das ist ja Putins Problem sonst hätte er
das doch schon längst gemacht es ist ja
nicht freiwillig so dass er da in der
Ukraine so dermaßen in die bredulie
geraten ist er hat ein Krieg angefangen
bei dem er sich nicht durchsetzen kann
also diese leernen Drohungen muss man
ignorieren und er hat ja vorher so getan
als wäre er attms eine sonst was wie
schlimme Eskalation von Seiten der
Amerikaner und dann würde er aber ganz
schlimme Dinge tun gemacht hat er nichts
er hat im Fernsehen gesagt das ist ein
Fehler wie bei anderen Dingen auch aber
es gibt eigentlich überhaupt keine
folgen wir sollten daraus lernen was die
Lieferung von Taurus betrifft da sind
keine schlimmen Folgen zu er warten und
was die nuklearen Drohung betrifft das
ist psychologische Kriegführung die auch
ganz gezielt immer wieder mit Bezug auf
Deutschland eingesetzt wird weil man
weiß sobort irgendwie das Wort nuklear
auftaucht oder sobald im Parlament so
ein Beschluss gefasst wird den ich in
der Sache für nicht besonders
bedeutungsvoll halte dann wird das
berichtet dann kriegen Leute Angst
insbesondere in Ländern die die Ukraine
unterstützen und das ist auch eine Form
der Abschreckung durch diese nuklearen
Drohung
nukleare Gefahr sehe ich überhaupt nicht
lassen Sie uns mal zur Bundesregierung
schauen Herr Lange es soll weitere
rüstungshilfen auch aus Deutschland
geben für die Ukraine
Verteidigungsminister Pistorius kündigte
da ein neues Paket an 400 Millionen Euro
schwer vor allem zusätzliche Munition
wolle man da liefern der Bundeskanzler
hat sich heute auch in seiner
Regierungserklärung ebenfalls dazu
geäußert da können wir mal ganz kurz
reinhören was er gesagt hat mit dem im
Europäischen Rat darüber beraten was wir
zu tun haben wie wir die Ukraine weiter
unterstützen und da geht es natürlich
auch darum wie wir es hinbekommen dass
jetzt konkret in diesem Winter das
Notwendige getan wird wir in Deutschland
machen das indem wir ein Winterpaket
Schnüren das viele Aspekte beinhaltet
insbesondere aber auch all das was zur
Luftverteidigung notwendig ist indem wir
dafür sorgeragen dass es eine
zusätzliche Patriot Einheit gibt die
dort eingesetzt werden kann neue ir
geliefert werden neue gepad und neue
Munition die dazu erforderlich ist auch
das gehört für uns dazu dass wir es der
Ukraine er möglichen sich gegen die
furchtbaren Raketenangriffe gegen die
Drohnen gegen alles das was gegen die
Infrastruktur und die zivile
Infrastruktur der Ukraine gerichtet ist
wir werden darin nicht nachlassen der
geepart und Munition Herr lange braucht
das die Ukraine aktuell denn eigentlich
wünscht man sich ja von den Deutschen
taurusmchl
ja man kann das eine ja tun ohne das
andere zu lassen find auf jeden Fall ein
bisschen schwierig wenn die Logik sein
soll na ja
taarus liefern wir nicht mit
Begründungen die
wechseln aber dafür schicken wir
sozusagen als Ersatz eine zusätzliche
Patriot Batterie das wäre falsch Patriot
wird gebraucht ganz sicher um die
zivilen Infrastrukturen um die Städte zu
schützen auch agres wird gebraucht
obwohl man da sagen muss die Dinge die
in den Paketen enthalten sind sind ja
die Dinge die schon mehrfach vorher
angekündigt worden sind die werden jetzt
eben nach und nach geliefert und da ist
der entscheidende Punkt was bisher nicht
gelungen ist ist die
Produktionskapazitäten so zu steigern
dass man schneller liefern kann also das
ist schön wenn man sagt man liefert
beständig aber das heißt ja im Grunde
nur man liefert in kleinen Häppchen weil
man auch nur in kleinen Häppchen
produzieren kann wenn man da langfristig
systematisch unterstützen will muss man
viel mehr produzieren können und muss
dann mit Abnahme gantien oder anderen
Instrumenten die Industrie dazu bringen
mehr zu produzieren und das ist
natürlich richtig Luftverteidigung zu
liefern und die Ukraine braucht viel
mehr und es ist genauso richtig für
Nachschub zu sorgen bei den
Präzisionswaffen die für die Ukraine so
bedeutsam sind weil sie damit Schläge
gegen Stäbe gegen Führungsstrukturen
gegen Kommunikationsstrukturen und vor
allen Dingen gegen die russische
Logistik durchführen kann und am Ende
kann sich vor dieser Frage niemand
drücken wenn die Ukraine sich in der S
Ukraine militärisch durchsetzen soll
dann muss man ihr die Instrumente dafür
in die Hand geben z.B auch die Brücken
zur Krim zu zerstören darüber läuft der
militärische Nachschub für die
russischen Truppen und es ist doch
inkonsequent wenn wir sagen wir wollen
dass die Ukraine nicht verliert wir
wollen dass Russland keinen Gewinn hat
durch diesen Angriffskrieg aber dann
liefern wir immer nur tröpfchenweise und
nie alles zusammen das was die Ukraine
eigentlich braucht um zu
gewinnenm das also erstmal die deutsche
Zusage lich zumindest die Ukraine wird
ja auch von anderen Ländern beliefert
z.B die USA die eben in dieser Woche
attackems Raketen geliefert hatten hier
gab es jetzt auch eine Frage eines Users
der anonym bleiben möchte allgemein mal
mit Blick auf beschlossene Militärhilfen
auf längere Sicht man weiß ja nicht wie
lange der Krieg noch gehen wird wie
beeinflusst z.B ein Regierungswechsel
z.B in den USA diese Lieferungen
wirklich kann sich das vielleicht
negativ auf die Ukraine
auswirken was ich zunächst n mal negativ
auswirkt ist ja schon diese
haushaltsblockade und das ist ja ein
Vorgeschmack weil die Republikaner
offensichtlich vor allen Dingen in der
Frage der Hilfe für die Ukraine
gespalten sind das ist zumindest ein
Faktor jetzt gibt es vielleicht
Möglichkeiten das noch mal zu überwinden
möglicherweise ein gemeinsamen
Hilfspaket für die Ukraine und Israel
aber trotzdem müssen die Amerikaner
zunächst mal im Repräsentantenhaus ein
Speaker wählen sonst geht gar nichts und
nach der
Wahl ist eben die Ukraine etwas die
ukrainehilfe etwas was ein neuer
Präsident wenn er das will sofort
stoppen könnte ist ja auch jetzt so dass
die Initiative für die militärilfe der
Ukraine aus dem Weißen Haus kommt und
dann immer vom Kongress die Mittel dafür
bereitgestellt werden und wenn man das
nicht mehr Macht und dem Kongress solche
Beschlüsse nicht vorlegt dann gibt's
eben auch keine Militärhilfe mehr das
ist ja ein Grund mehr warum wir Europäer
über die Frage wie können wir
langfristig systematisch die Ukraine
unterstützen wie können wir auch mehr
produzieren wie können wir mindestens
mal auf Augenhöhe kommen mit den
Amerikanern so eine wichtige Frage ist
und da sind die großen Industrienationen
in Europa gefragt das ist Deutschland
das ist aber auch Frankreich Italien
Spanien Polen Großbritannien also die
Europäer müssten sich eigentlich an
dieser Stelle jetzt mal zusammensetzen
und gemeinsam planen wie sie die Ukraine
militärisch weiter ausstatten das wird
nicht von allein passieren und durch
Wunschdenken wird das auch nicht besser
werden das ist aber weiter in unserem
Interesse das ist ja nicht dass wir da
Beobachter sind wir haben großes
Interesse daran weil die Sicherheit für
die Menschen in Deutschland auf jeden
Fall erheblich schlechter wäre und die
Gefahren für uns viel größer wenn
Russland in der Ukraine da weitere
Gewinne hätte mhm das war jetzt ihre
Einschätzung zur Ukraine wir haben von
Andreas via YouTube eine Frage zur
russischen Seite bekommen Herr Lange wie
schätzen sie denn die
Produktionskapazitäten der Russen
aktuell noch ein ja russland hat
umgestellt in der Wirtschaft
Putin hat da sehr große Anstrengungen
unternommen hat sich auch persönlich
dafür eingesetzt Russland glaubt durch
diese Umstellung in der Lage zu sein
mehr zu produzieren als wir die wir die
Ukraine unterstützen was ich im übrigen
lächerlich finde wenn die führenden
Industrienationen der Welt nicht in der
Lage sind mehr zu produzieren als
Russland aber im Moment tun wir nicht
das notwendige und Putin hat ein
besseres Gefühl bestimmte wa kann er
nicht produzieren weil durch
technologische Sanktionen und diese
Sanktionen generell manche Bauteile
nicht gefertigt werden können oder nicht
zur Verfügung stehen aber man muss
leider sagen viele Unternehmen
ich finde das sehr schlimm auch deutsche
Unternehmen umgehen die Sanktionen und
liefern Bauteile auch für Waffen oder
dual use Bauteile die auch für Waffen
für marsflugkörper z.B genutzt werden da
müssen wir in Deutschland und in der EU
auch gucken dass man dem ein Riegel
vorschiebt ich finde das unerträg dass
deutsche Unternehmen europäische
Unternehmen die Sanktionen umgehen und
dann zu diesem Kriegsmaterial beitragen
und es gibt aber auch z.B
Artilleriemunition Waffensysteme die in
Russland entwickelt worden sind die
nicht so weit entwickelt sind die kann
Russland mit eigenen Ressourcen mit
eigener
Technologie sehr lange produzieren aber
auch da muss man sich fragen warum
gibt's immer noch
maschinenbauhersteller die Russland
Maschinen liefern die auch für die
Waffenproduktion genutzt werden also ich
glaube die Dinge muss man sich dann noch
mal angucken stand heute ist es aber so
dass Russland das Gefühl hat es kann
mehr z.B Artilleriemunition produzieren
als das die Europäer tun und dann setzt
Putin eben darauf na ja wenn dann
vielleicht in den USA etwas anderes
passiert politisch und die Europäer die
Sache nicht auf die Kette kriegen dann
hat er eine Chance sich am Ende diesem
Krieg sogar durchzusetzen ja da spielen
viele Faktoren eine Rolle zum Abschluss
Herl lang lassen Sie es uns mal
bilanzieren der Winter kommt welche
Ziele dürften Ukraine und Russland
militärisch jetzt
verfolgen also ein kurzfristiges Ziel
ich habe das ja angedeutet beim Kampf
der gerade bei afdfka stattfindet und
vielleicht auch an anderen
Frontabschnitten ist die ganz einfache
taktische Frage zu entscheiden wer kann
in einer Stadt und in Infrastrukturen
überwintern und wer muss das in Stellung
auf dem offenen Feld tun das macht in
der Ostukraine wo es sehr kalt wird im
Winter macht das einen großen
Unterschied im Süden ist es vielleicht
nicht so der Faktor ähm wir müssen
glaube ich von unseren historischen
Stalingrad und Winterkrieg Bildern Weg
das ist nicht das was in der Ukraine
passiert deswegen gehe ich davon aus
dass den gesamten winterüber auch
Kampfhandlungen weiter stattfinden
werden die Ukraine hat mehr Fahrzeuge
auf Ketten als sie das z.B im letzten
Jahr hatte das heißt sie ist auch unter
Witterungsbedingungen die schwieriger
sind in der Lage bewegungsfähig zu sein
also wir werden weiter Kampfhandlung
sehen die Ukraine hat jetzt mit
attackemess neue Instrumente und wird
jetzt jetzt die Gegenoffensive nach
einer operativen Pause mit diesen neuen
Instrumenten weiterführen und man muss
ja sagen die Gegenoffensive hat ja einen
wichtigen Erfolg erreicht weil die
Westseite der Krim nicht nur was die
russische luftab
Luftverteidigung die russischen
Radarsysteme geschwächt worden ist
sondern auch weil die russische Flotte
vertrieben worden ist aus sastopol und
von der Westseite der Krim und das hat
ja dazu geführt dass die Ukraine
mittlerweile mit 33 Schiffen wieder
Getreide exportieren konnte also da
gibt's ja wichtige Erfolge die erreicht
worden sind auf die die Ukraine aufbauen
wird ich gehe auch davon aus dass die
Ukraine die Angriffe auf die Krim und
aufs russische Hinterland mit drohen und
mit in der Ukraine selbst hergestellten
Waffensystem fortsetzen wird den ganzen
Winter über aktuelle Einschätzungen von
Militärexperte Nico lange waren das Herr
Lange vielen Dank für Ihre Zeit danke
für das Gespräch
gerne ja und das war unser Ukrainer
Update für heute in ZDF heute live
vielen Dank für alle eure Fragen und
Kommentare wir hoffen Euch hat's
gefallen euch interessiert das weiter
natürlich werden wir die Lage weiterhin
im Blick behalten und dann hier auch im
Update drüber berichten euch einen
schönen Abend und bis
[Musik]
bald